we were always successful in everything
but school didn't do owns for poor
terrible actually I'm not necessarily
the best spokesperson for this message
but like unless there's a really really
good reason to leave college you really
should finish college
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I often get asked is it
worth it to go to college if I want to
be an entrepreneur
so my continuation this series stay
we're gonna look at what Gary Vaynerchuk
and Mark Zuckerberg think enjoy were
always successful in everything but
school didn't do all school poor
terrible actually punted it you know it
was funny and this is where I give my
parents enormous credit and I've you
know it's funny it's a business book
that's his self-awareness my parents
grew up and I give them so much credit
in a world where all their
contemporaries and you know this
education is the way out for immigrants
my mom recognized that I was a merchant
an entrepreneur a promoter that school
failure you failed school school failed
me schools failing entrepreneurs every
single day it was because it's not built
for entrepreneurship it's built for
workers you know if you're being taught
to play within the lines and there's
nothing being taught that maps to the
entrepreneurial market as a matter of
fact my biggest cynicism when I sit
across an entrepreneur today is if they
are too successful at school I probably
look at Ivy League grad starting
startups right now with more of a
negative light than I do somebody who
wasn't as good because what I've learned
over the last five to seven years and by
the way in the last two or three years
I've taken a step back on this because
there's too many entrepreneurial friends
who've gone to great schools that have
been successful so this is not a blanket
statement but I will tell you that in a
world of private schools in a world of
mommy and daddy having a lot of
connections that when you go from 12 15
18 years of that ecosystem and you go
into a market and you create an app the
market doesn't give a crap who your dad
is
the market responds to your product and
a lot of these kids have not been able
to take the punch in the mouth that
comes along with entrepreneurship my
question for you do you think a
bachelor's degree with your expiry
experience with college naved you think
a bachelor's degree is a necessary key
to attaining success oh I am NOT your
role model on this one yeah absolutely
stay in school I think it helps I loved
I loved the time that I spend in college
I wish I could have gotten more time I
did not choose to leave I just happened
to build Facebook and it kind of made me
leave but if I had the opportunity to to
learn for two more years in college and
colleges this magical time right where
you get to explore different interests
and focus on different things and meet
great people and that is not something
that I would have wanted to have given
up and if I could have magically both
done if I could have done Facebook in my
senior year I would have done that or
after I left I would have done that and
I wish I could have stayed in college
but and of course there's no doubt I
mean there's a lot of research that
shows that having a bachelor degree
absolutely does help increase your job
potential your earnings potential
all that so yeah I mean look I mean it's
kind of crazy for you know I'm not
necessarily the best spokesperson for
this message but like unless there's a
really really good reason to leave
college you really should finish college
don't even me I'm I'm going back to
college to get I'm gonna get a degree
this year
Harvard finally allowed me to come back
[Applause]
and I have to say you know I think that
this is probably gonna be the thing that
my parents are most proud of me for so
so look yes
I'm not the right messenger but stay in
school
now I've got two very special bonus
clips with advice from Gary and mark to
help you on your journey but before that
I want to know who did you agree with
are you on Gary side are you a mark side
please share your thoughts leave it down
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is
much-loved see you soon
if you are 22 years old and graduating
from college if you're 22 years old and
not graduating from college if you are
22 years old you are entering first of
all some of the greatest years of your
life a but being this this is the moment
watch this video twice if Mama's
watching this send this to your daughter
Sally right now because you have to
understand this next five year window is
when you don't go practical and safe
this is not the time to get the job mom
wanted you to this is not the time to
try to maximize as much money so you can
buy a loaf at WIPP this is the time to
realize that you've a five-year window
and it's three for some it's eight for
others but there's a five new window for
you to attack the life that you want to
win not because it's the secret because
the world so Zen because it's hardest
out there as a matter of fact I'm
probably more scared about your naivete
to how hard class is easy right what
you've been doing for the last 16 years
is easy it's a [ __ ] game it's
structured it's easy the world this
thing this thing is hard however that
contradicts what I'm gonna tell you
right now which is this is the best and
easiest five years of your life because
this is when you need to attack what you
love and what you want to do here's why
you don't have all the baggage you may
have college loans respect it's Harnish
you may have the expectations of your
parents mentally hard fake hard you may
have a lot of other things but this is
exactly when you can live with four
roommates in a basement and eat fast
food do you understand this is not when
the baby's there some of your babies
this is not when you've been married and
you promised this is not when the world
is sucked out all your dreams and hopes
yet you've still got this window and yet
so many of you are so hungry for short
term short term games like maximizing
the job that paid these three thousand
dollars more but it's not as fun but you
want that three thousand dollars for
what for what for a new iPhone for what
you get to live life one
and this is the time right now to
understand what's actually happening and
actually map your behavior to something
that will impact you for the next 80
years so promise me promise me all you
youngsters that are watching this right
now in the comments because I'll jump in
and talk to you promise me that you
understand that the land grab of
happiness starts right now now you don't
have to worry about getting that job
what you should do is go and travel and
learn go and start that business that
you've always wanted hook up with those
three teammates and start that band
you've always wanted this is the time to
be massively risk massively risk
oriented I know that this is when you're
supposed to grow up and go see the world
but guess what the world isn't what
mommy and daddy told you the world is
exactly going to be what it's going to
be with or without the way you thought
it was going to be a ton of is gonna
change the world changes every goddamn
day right now what you need to recognize
is you can afford to but the students
around me were really important as well
right and both in high school and in
college I mean the people who started
Facebook with me and a lot of people who
are still with me running the company
today are people who I met when I was at
Harvard and some of them were my tf's at
Harvard right and you know when the
professors were off writing papers these
were the people who actually taught me
and then we hung out and we had like
social bonds and academic bonds and I
just I wouldn't understate the
importance of that and I mean it's very
tied into my whole philosophy and the
product that that I've spent my life
building Facebook because we just
believe that social bonds are critical
and um in one way that I think about the
the value that Facebook is filling in
the world is that you go through school
and at least when I did people just
focused on you know academics like
achievement different areas and one of
the things that no one really ever
taught me was like having friends is
really valuable no I'm not that I didn't
have friends but but like although you
know the movie yes I could seem that
but that first round is for sure I don't
think anyone is like it's not like okay
third grade we're gonna like
now we're gonna like teach you that like
hanging out with people is a very
important development right and I don't
know I actually think that that is and I
think that's part of the reason why
sometimes people view Facebook as a
waste of time but I actually think it's
this extremely socially valuable utility
and I know that I wouldn't be where I
want where I am today without that
aspect of my life being as developed as
the academic part if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it you act like I
have Tulsa what a whale out of
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access